Hallo Wolfgang.
Hallo Stefan.
Wo sind wir? Was machen wir?
Wir wollen nur kurz sagen, was wir lesen werden, aber du hast uns noch einen Clip mitgebracht.
Na, wir sagen zuerst, was wir lesen und dann bett ich's ein. Was lesen wir?
Also, wir lesen das neue Buch von Richard David Precht, das Jahrhundert der
Toleranz, Plädoyer für eine wertegeleitete Außenpolitik,
erschienen bei Goldman, Goldmann, oder genauer gesagt, es erscheint bei Goldmann am 30.
Mai und dieses Buch wird sicherlich für Furore sorgen,
denn zwar lesen wir hier von wertegeleiteter Außenpolitik im Untertitel,
aber er meint wohl doch etwas sehr anderes als das, was jetzt so gerade von
der Ampelregierung darunter verstanden wird.
Wenn man in den Klappentext, der schon veröffentlicht wurde,
hineinliest, dann erfährt man dort, dass Richard David Precht sich darum sorgt,
dass wir auf globaler Ebene immer seltener bereit sind, auf Feindbilder zu verzichten.
Und da heißt es, auf die Schablonen Christen gegen Heiden, Zivilisierte gegen
Wilde, Freiheit gegen Kommunismus, christlich-abendländische Kultur gegen den Islam,
Volk nun, Demokratien gegen Autokratien.
Und die Fragen, die sich daran anschließen, lauten, wer hat dieses Narrativ in die Welt gesetzt?
Welche Interessen stehen dahinter? Warum ist es so erfolgreich?
Und ist es zielführend, das dann auch weiter zu verfolgen?
Und er plädiert für ein Jahrhundert der Toleranz, dass die einzige Möglichkeit
sei, um aus diesem Entweder-Oder, um aus diesem einfachen Freund-Feind-Schema auszubrechen.
Und er nennt schon das Wort Schablone. Dort im Sinne von Denkschablone und so.
Das finde ich interessant, denn das kommt auch gleich in einem Clip vor.
Wir hören mal einen Clip gleich sozusagen als Hausaufgabe. Denn wir wissen ja
noch gar nicht, selbst am 30., wenn wir den Podcast dann aufnehmen,
für den Monat, kommt das Buch gerade. Also auch dann wissen wir noch nicht.
Das heißt, wir können ja jetzt blind der Lektüre, wie wir sind,
einfach ein paar, nicht Anforderungen, aber Fragen stellen, die wir so haben.
Und wir kennen ja Precht im Grunde als Autor. Ist ja nicht das erste Buch, was wir lesen.
Und dieses Denken über Außenpolitik ist ja interessant,
weil wir uns ja auch schon gefragt haben, was ist jetzt feministische Außenpolitik,
müssten wir sie nicht eigentlich nochmal retten, also als Idee und steckt da
nicht doch was dahinter, ist nicht die Realität, wie wir sie sehen,
Sinnbild eines Bedarfes an solchen Sachen und so weiter.
Und wir haben ja zuletzt bei Rutger Breschmann uns gefragt, was hat es mit diesen Politikern auf sich?
Also klare Unterscheidung von Politiker und Publikum und dann,
was hat es mit diesen Politikern auf sich?
Wir haben jetzt gerade diese Dädenerhöhung gehabt, die 6% mehr Lohn für die
Politiker bedeutet, die dafür nicht streiken mussten und einfach mal so mehr
als ein Bürgergeld pro Monat mehr bekommen.
So, da kann man sich ja schon wieder die Frage stellen, was hat es mit diesen
Politikern irgendwie auf sich? Das hat doch eine besondere Rolle.
Und jetzt hatten wir ja gesagt, wir wollen modern denken.
Und das Demokratiedämmerungsbuch hat uns ja schon auch ein bisschen angeleitet,
nochmal zu hinterfragen, wie denken wir darüber nach, was wir leben.
Also wie steht die Demokratietheorie zur Demokratie.
So, dieses Buch, glaube ich, lässt uns jetzt wirklich darüber nachdenken,
moderne Rollenverteilung.
Also, was hat es mit diesen Politikern auf sich? und zweitens,
gibt es denn einen Maßstab für diese moderne Rolle Politiker?
Was ist gute und was ist schlechte Politik?
Denn meine Vermutung ist, wenn Precht wie immer nah am Zeitgeist ist,
nah am Gegenwärtigen, so wie er
auch ein Buch über die Medien während der Corona-Pandemie geschrieben hat,
um nicht nochmal eine weitere Stimme zu sein, die auch was zum Virus schreibt,
sondern zu diesem medialen Reflex darüber, Darüber habe ich eigentlich die ganz
große Erwartung, dass wir da...
Ja, zum Krieg war es ja vor allem.
Oder zum Krieg, also Corona als Anlass und Krieg dann als Katalysator sozusagen,
um mal diesen Punkt aufzumachen.
Wie reden wir über das, was wir leben und wie könnte es anders sein?
Also wirklich handlungsleidend.
Und bei Geopolitik denke ich mir jetzt, da sind wir ja als normale Menschen
insbesondere Zaungäste, Zuschauer.
Also es gibt jetzt viele Politikfelder, wo wir sagen, da bräuchten wir mal einen
Klassenkampf, da müsste man mal das und das machen, aber bei Geopolitik,
also wenn sich jetzt Putin neben Xi auf die Tribüne setzt,
um eine Militärparade zu sehen, da wüssten wir jetzt nicht, wo wir jetzt Handlungsleitenden
da irgendwie eingreifen.
Und da stecken so viele Fragen drin und das Schablone, also Denkschablone,
finde ich, ist jetzt wirklich ein ganz wichtiger Grundbegriff,
wird wahrscheinlich für unsere Diskussion dann sein.
Und ich will nochmal ein Clip spielen aus dem letzten Podcast von Lanz und Precht,
wo das so ein bisschen schon zur Geltung kommt. Und ich sage gleich dazu,
wenn man den Clip jetzt länger hören würde, kriegt man nicht mehr Aufklärung.
Also wir müssen jetzt einfach wirklich warten, wie so eine Denkfigur dann entfaltet wird im Buch.
Aber Lanz versucht mal so eine Minute lang so ganz, ja hier sollte man nicht
so und so, wo man so fast denkt, ist das nicht zu schnelles Denken?
Ist das nicht nicht modernes Denken? Steckt hier nicht noch irgendwas und so?
Und dann kommt Precht und sagt einfach, nee, wir brauchen eine andere Denkschablone.
Und das, also dieser eine Clip steigert sozusagen mein Interesse für so ein
Buch, wie wir es jetzt bekommen, ungemein.
In der alten Bundesrepublik, da gab es sozusagen das Bild eines gesellschaftlichen
Konfliktes von oben nach unten.
So hat das Holger Lengfeld, bekannter Soziologe aus Leipzig, dieser Tage gesagt.
An der Spitze steht jemand, der die ökonomischen Ressourcen besitzt.
Also die Deutung ist ein Klassenkonflikt, der primär ein Verteilungskonflikt war.
Und er sagt, jetzt ist etwas Interessantes passiert.
Konflikte, die uns heute bewegen, kreisen vermehrt um die Frage,
wie eine gute Gesellschaft auszusehen hat und welchen Platz ich darin einnehme.
Und er sagt, da gibt es einen Teil der Gesellschaft, der sozusagen eine sehr
starke Einstellung herausgebildet hat, so nach dem Motto, oben die Elite und unten das Volk.
Und er sagt, das sieht aus wie der Klassenkonflikt von früher,
ist aber hochmoralisch aufgeladen.
Die Lesart ist, das Volk ist gut, das Volk ist ehrlich, das Volk zahlt,
der einfache Mann zahlt selbstverständlich seine Steuern, macht nichts schwarz,
ist ein ehrlicher Mann, der von morgens bis abends betuppt und betrogen wird.
Die Elite dagegen ist korrupt und beutet genau diesen einfachen,
ehrlichen Mann bewusst und in jeglicher Hinsicht aus.
Und finde, da hat er einen Punkt. Ja, ich fremdele ein bisschen,
also nicht mit den Beobachtungen, aber ich fremdele ein bisschen mit den Schablonen.
Lanz sagt im Grunde das, was wir alle hören wollen.
Wir, die einfachen Leute, die Zuschauer der Politik, wir werden doch ausgebeutet,
hier kommen doch Leute, die uns sozusagen übervorteilen wollen und so weiter.
Alle fühlen sich wohl eigentlich mit so einer Beschreibung und dann sagt Precht, nein,
ich fremdele so ein bisschen mit dieser Schablone und ich erhoffe mir eigentlich
allergrößte Aufklärung in diesem Felde, wo wir sagen, Precht ist der Autor,
der wie kein anderer ein Publikum begeistern kann,
weil er es nochmal reinholt in ein Thema.
Und gleichzeitig nutzt er aber als Thema die Geopolitik, wo ich denke,
oh, da wird es am allerschwierigsten, dem Einzelnen nochmal mehr als eine Zuschauerrolle zuzutrauen.
In der Hinsicht freue ich mich auf das Buch fast noch mehr als vorher,
obwohl mich diese Gegenwärtigkeit und diese Zeitgeistigkeit,
die da drinsteckt, damals ja schon sehr begeistert hat.
Also ich bin sehr froh, dass so ein Buch jetzt kommt.
Mir schien es aber jetzt bei diesem Lanz-Clip eher so,
dass Lanz diese Position referiert, dass die in der Bevölkerung weit verbreitet ist,
dass das Volk immer grundsätzlich gut ist und die Elite verroht ist und unmoralisch
handelt und dass da diese Opposition besteht.
Ich würde sagen, das ist im Übrigen eine Beobachtung, die es natürlich immer
wieder gibt, die ist aber uralt, also dass die einfachen Leute sich als die
ehrlichen Leute identifizieren und mitunter stimmt das ja auch.
Es ist jetzt nicht so, dass es alle reinen Gewissens sind, aber es ist doch
so, dass wir gerade bei dem Politikertypus ja eine gewisse Anfälligkeit für gewisse Dinge finden,
was wir ja bei Prechtmann ausbuchstabiert bekommen.
Dass das merkwürdige Persönlichkeiten sind, die Politiker werden.
Und ich erinnere mich zum Beispiel auch an Historiker, die sich mit der Französischen
Revolution beschäftigt haben und wo man auch,
ehe die Französische Revolution begann, sehr klar diese Opposition aufgemacht
hat von einer sehr unmoralisch handelnden Elite und einem moralisch handelnden Volk.
Ich glaube, dass man damit nicht sehr weit kommt.
Ich glaube aber, dass das doch so sehr verankert ist.
Was mich eigentlich an dem Buch von Precht am meisten interessiert ist,
wie kommt man also dadurch zwischen einem ganz moralistischen Anspruch, der nur sagt,
wir verteidigen die Demokratie, wo immer es geht und wir wissen die ganze Zeit,
dass Deutschland diesem Anspruch nicht gerecht wird und Menschenrechte auch
ausblendet, wenn das jetzt gerade nicht der Staatsräson oder so entspricht.
Und auf der anderen Seite haben wir die Realisten, die sagen, es geht nur darum.
Um kalte Machtkonfrontationen, um Blöcke und da muss man austarieren und ich
will in den nächsten Podcast mal ein bisschen diese realistische Perspektive
mitbringen, weil sie zumindest sehr viel weiterführender ist,
sehr viel analytischer ist, als diese so hochmoralisch aufgeladene und das soll
also in der regulären Folge stattfinden und dann haben wir damit eine gute Grundlage,
um über das Buch zu diskutieren, ob es also doch einen Weg zwischen diesen beiden
Positionen gibt, ohne dass man das,
was man unter Werte versteht, gänzlich verrät und ohne dass man ausblendet,
dass es tatsächlich auch kalte Machtkonfrontationen gibt,
in denen Werte eher keine Rolle spielen, Interessen aber umso wichtiger sind.
Ja, du wirst den Realismus im Großen und Ganzen mitbringen. Ich werde das Problem
Dummheit im Kleinen noch mitbringen für die reguläre Folge.
Und so wie du eben meintest, du sympathisierst mit dem, was Lanz da so anschneidet
als Denkfigur, eben wir alle, ich auch.
Und trotzdem kommt Brecht und sagt, er möchte eine neue Schablone vorstellen.
Da können wir also sehr gespannt sein, wie das Buch sich dann entfaltet.
In den Salon.
Ja, genau. Das wollte ich dich gerade fragen, wie man in den Salon kommt.
In den Salon kommt man, indem man die Straße runter links, nicht rechts geht, nein.
Man geht auf neue20er.de und folgt dem goldenen Button. Dann ist man bei Steady.
Ab dann ist alles selbsterklärend.
Und die Zielsetzung für jeden, der in den Salon möchte, ist,
Man will zu seinem RSS-Feed. Man bucht also ein Paket seiner Wahl,
das billigste zum Beispiel,
und dann kriegt man einen RSS-Feed, der steht schon in der E-Mail,
die man als Bestätigung bekommt, und den kann man einfach in seinen Podcatcher,
egal welchen, eintragen und dann bekommt man jede neue Salonfolge serviert mit
Kapitelmarken, mit einem Cover, wo das Datum draufsteht und wo die Bücher abgebildet
sind, dann sieht man gleich, wo man ist.
Oder wenn man es sich einfach machen will und sowieso über die Apple Podcast
App hört, lädt man einfach in der regulären Neue20er, im Neuen20er-Feed dann
die, da steht dann, kostet Geld, Abonnierung oder irgendwas,
also Folge nur für Abonnenten oder so, kann man draufklicken,
kostet dann Euro mehr pro Folge als bei Steady.
Oder wenn man einen Patreon-Account schon hat und weiß, wie das da funktioniert,
sucht man uns einfach dort.
Und man kann dann sehr viele Folgen noch nachhören. Wir haben schon über sehr
viele Bücher gesprochen,
unter anderem auch über das schon von dir angesprochene Buch von Richard David
Precht und Harald Welzer über die Medien und dieses aktualisiert sich ja tagtäglich.
Ja, also man kann jedenfalls diese Folge ohne Probleme jetzt zum ersten Mal
hören und wird nicht den Eindruck haben, dass man dort einen alten Hut in der Hand hat.
Insofern freuen wir uns, wenn wir mehr Salon-Abonnenten begrüßen dürfen und
wir freuen uns, wenn wir uns am Ende des Monats hören.
So ist es. Bis denn.